so what is this thing doing on the floor
that's we don't have to worry about that
we're going to read the book now okay
Johnny's a boy with a big imagination
one day he's a dog the next day a
crustacean it's like a crab or a lobster
one morning he came downstairs barking
and clapping wood spoons for tusks and
sock fins a flapping it spoons his mouth
he's pretending to be a walrus
I'm Johnny The Walrus he said with a
roar the wood floor is my ocean the
carpet's my Shore swimming around like a
walrus isn't that silly Johnny's mom
loves her sons make believe time your
Johnny The Walrus till you change your
mind mommy says but Johnny's mom's phone
said it's not just pretend so she went
on her phone and there were people
telling her that this isn't pretend he's
really a walrus only a bigot would say
that how dare you offend what's up bigot
anybody know